wahre liebe elisabeth die mama von poldi
diese sprachnachricht geistert derzeit
von handy zu handy und ist falsch
darin warnt die mama von poldi davor
dass ibuprofen das corona virus
beschleunigt angebliche quelle uniklinik
wien eine falsche information wie die
uniklinik immer wieder auf ihren
sozialen plattformen erklärt was ist den
leuten so schwer macht da manchmal
zwischen baar und falsch zu
unterscheiden ist dass wir einfach
geneigt und das zu glauben
weniger zu hinterfragen wenn freunde
bekannte verwandte etwas teilen zum
beispiel per whatsapp die nachrichten
verbreiten sich in der gesellschaft per
verschlüsselter direktnachricht wie ein
virus
was told whatsapp dagegen bei whatsapp
bekämpfen der virale botschaften in dem
wir weitergeleitete inhalte als solche
markieren und die möglichkeit eine
nachricht weiterzuleiten auf nur fünf
gruppen begrenzen
zudem bieten wir behörden und
gesundheits organisationen auf der
ganzen welt an
whatsapp zur aufklärungsarbeit und der
verbreitung verlässliche informationen
zu nutzen sind aus meiner sicht sehr
schwache maßnahmen natürlich können sich
trotzdem weiter falsch nachrichten viral
verbreiten
bei whatsapp da sehe ich jetzt dadurch
keinen keinen hinderungsgrund und ich
denke das ist jetzt wirklich angezeigt
dass deutlich mehr unternimmt das machen
die anderen vertrauen zum teil ja auch
wer auf youtube nach informationen über
das corona virus sucht findet jetzt
diesen link zur bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung ähnliches bei
facebook und instagram bisher sind ja
suchmaschinen sind soziale netzwerke
wirklich nicht gerade mit besonders viel
ehrgeiz aufgefallen wenn es darum ging
falschinformationen einzudämmen
das ist jetzt durchaus anders also es
gibt eine prominente verlinkung
glaubhafter plan so als würde ich mir
ehrlich gesagt häufiger wünschen
in diesem konzept kettenbrief sind sogar
mehrere falsche informationen ein arzt
will erfahren haben dass ganz normale
masken vor dem virus schützen und das
virus bei einer temperatur von 26 bis 27
grad stirbt alles nicht wissenschaftlich
belegt solche nachrichten gilt es
einzudämmen
das wichtigste ist aus meiner sicht
nicht einfach so weiterleiten ohne
sichergestellt zu haben dass es auch
eine vernünftige information ist also
wenn man zeit hat einfach die sache
versuchen wenigstens kurz auf den grund
zu gehen ist das eine verlässliche
quelle zb das gesundheitsministerium das
robert-koch-institut oder die
weltgesundheitsorganisation